um all right so
I was going to call it an EP almost
[ __ ] up the project the 60s the sixth
piece is out right now pretty much music
single life
pretty [ __ ] music is on the way is on
the way
um what's your favorite song on the uh
single life
they're all my favorite that's a stupid
answer no for real damn why you gotta be
so mean because you gotta pick what I
gotta pick one okay today what's your
favorite what's the mood I don't know
what is your mood right now right now
what's your favorite right now what's my
favorite
um
um they all got different Vibes you butt
dialing somebody oops Jesus
um
I don't know
all of them all of them yeah that's a
typical typical thing to say about your
new music yeah but it's a real answer I
respect it um
yeah well all of them
and uh we're gonna get the album at the
beginning of the year sometime sometime
maybe first quarter
huh I'm not sure yet
not sure yet I still gotta heat up some
more
what does that mean it means just you
know
heating my name back up I feel like your
name is I mean your sweetie
um
it's funny when people say that I don't
know what that means because I still
feel like
I still I don't feel like that whatever
that means
hey that's dope that means that you're
still very motivated and you know you're
not content with where you are that's
what we happen to a lot of rappers that
get popping and they they end up like a
little pump
yeah damn I mean [ __ ] little punk he put
my number online he did yeah [ __ ] him
why he do that because he's a wiener we
should get in dick pics
no but do you want me let me show you
what I got what it wasn't blurred out
though
hold on
I gotta show you this this is terrible
so he put my number up because you still
got the same number yeah I mean it was
he put it up for like five minutes
so why you push our number up because we
did an interview and I asked him in an
interview if he thought J Cole predicted
his career properly because you know J
Cole said he was going to fall off and
uh
I mean it was a good interview I mean I
guess
but they were like hey like 10 minutes
before the interview was gonna drop they
were like you gotta you guys they didn't
even ask his manager was like you can't
put that interview out like out of
nowhere and I was like what do you mean
I can't uh-huh you know what I'm saying
like what so the interview came out and
um and then you put my phone number up
but this is the kind of [ __ ] I was
getting oh random giant pasty white tits
in my text messages like I didn't even
know a little pump had fans like that
anymore that would just like this one's
crazy the devil masonry Illuminati
whatever bro I'll sign pump hit me up
this is my Ig I'm 17 years old oh they
thought you was Lil pump yes oh no the
number he said everybody call me
that's hella funny yeah I'm sorry and
then like you know you can imagine the
the type of person that would attempt to
call a little pump in 2022 like what
kind of people they are you know what I
mean that's exactly who was hitting me
up I was I was driving to San Diego and
my [ __ ] was going crazy oh my goodness
did you have to block some people
I just uh put my phone in airplane mode
for like an hour oh okay so you didn't
get nothing yeah yeah I was like all
right I know what's happening here this
[ __ ] damn
terrible yeah yeah anyway